une tempête le traversier soudainement
reporté de 24 heures
c'est ainsi que le cauchemar a commencé
j'ai pensé plus en plus il ya un barrage
routier etc look que ce d'arrêter
dansant puis comme le bateau voyage à
pau le lendemain ben on m'a ordonné de
reprendre le chip ok mais que je le
croyais comme parce que dans les
conditions hivernales
j'ai dit que c'était début janvier après
avoir voyagé de québec jusqu'à les du
prince édouard pas question pour elle de
rebrousser chemin
l'argumentation avec les autorités a
duré presque trois heures il est
strictement défendu pour les québécois
qui se rendent aux îles-de-la-madeleine
de dormir à l'hôtel
que ce soit au nouveau brunswick ou à
l'île du prince édouard et avait pas de
négociations possibles
je ne suis ni à moi je me suis enrichi
puis au canada au moulin rouge umar
heures j'arrive pour deux mecs et
j'arrive comme je savais qu'on allait
chez nous fait que je trouvais ça
vraiment physique en situation comme
nous on était on était là la caisse pour
de vrai à l'époque les québécois
rentrent au nouveau brunswick on allait
tout la ramener le club en octobre après
une collision avec un orignal en pleine
nuit sur l'autoroute n'est le policier
ni le chauffeur de la dépanneuse n'a
voulu faire monter fanny barrette et son
conjoint dans un véhicule pour les
escorter jusqu'à la ville la plus proche
il leur a fallu supplier et payer le
chauffeur elle a beau avoir fait les
manchettes
la situation n'a pas changé puis il ya
personne qui table moi j'ai écrit pas
moins de quatre lettre au premier
ministre françois legault il n'a jamais
répondu de façon directe parfois j'ai eu
des réponses de ses ministres les
députés des îles-de-la-madeleine
souhaite l'implantation d'hôtels désigné
au nouveau brunswick
on pense que le risque beaucoup plus
important de prendre la route dans des
conditions non sécuritaire que de
permettre par exemple la légende arrêté
dans un hôtel y aurait des mesures
sanitaires en place plusieurs ateliers
du grand moncton accueille déjà des
travailleurs qui doivent s'isoler
ils sont outillés pour respecter les
mesures sanitaires la clientèle en
transit serait accueilli à bras ouverts
du style d'autant plus que l'industrie
touristique se meurt ici je suis
vraiment inquiète de voir combien de nos
exploitants vont être capables de
survivre un autre était de 50 à 100% de
moindres revenus
blaine et je crois que des hôtels
pourraient être identifiés et s'est
engagé à se pencher sur